there's now a 50% chance of World War I
as the Israel Hamas conflict threatens
to spread hedge fund Legend ralio This
is a 20 billion man says this is again
Insider
story so uh uh this may be the most
dangerous time the world has seen in
decades Jamie Diamond says if you can
pull up his Instagram so people can see
this as well hedge fund Legend Ray do
believes that the risk of transitioning
from contained conflict to an
uncontained hot world has risen from 35%
to 50% over the last 2 years stating in
my opinion this war has a high risk of
leading to several other conflicts of
different stating of different types in
a number of places and it is likely to
have harmful effects that will extend
beyond those in Israel and Gaza Dalia
who is known for his expertise in global
power shifts and historical Cycles
seized the Israel Hamas and Russia
Ukraine conflicts as brutal struggles
likely to persist until one side emerges
as the clear Victor and he warns if they
spread to other countries most
importantly the major countries there
will be a much more horrific uh uh hot
World War Tom what are your thoughts on
what Dalo is saying here as well as
Jamie Diamond well but Dalo and Jamie
Diamond don't want anything happen to
the US Equity markets that's what
they're very very concerned about is is
US asset prices us Equity markets so
they're sounding the alarm on one thing
and what it is is the escalation and
when you look at the chess board there
it is that's Jamie Dam this this may be
the most d ous time the world has seen
in decades go ahead Tom yeah so what is
he worried about this is what he worried
about you you got to look five moves
ahead and there's a nice man that wrote
a book your next five moves think about
the next moves here and the one that
everybody's worried about is you were
seeing it over the weekend was Iran
everybody all the ambassadors were going
to talk to Iran they're saying hey baby
stay in your corner stay in your corner
don't you know we know what you're
trying to do over there in in Syria
don't show up with arms don't show up
with support stay out of this and there
is a lot of work and that is what
everyone is worried about the escalation
of the conflict is not the Saudis it's
not the Egyptians the Egyptians are not
armed and the Saudis are not interested
in getting into full conflict it is Iran
and Syria making it a two-front war that
destabilizes energy which will have a
domino effect so you have leading
economic thinkers doio and Diamond
saying we don't want to see this
escalate and you can translate it down
to one sentence we don't want Iran to
get with Syria make it a two-front war
and make it a regional conflict which is
affect nearly a World War because of
what it's going to do the markets yeah I
think uh it begs the question uh what
would the current state of the world
look like under the presidency of Donald
Trump so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right
here